you
restaurant is the theater absolutes the
theater for all the senses my name is
charles misil i'm the director of the
restaurant sugar year at the back raha
Tellman residences I believe there are
five major ingredients in running a
great restaurant first of all you need
great food great food that seems very
simple the simplest dishes of the artist
to accomplish how its presented how it
served sets the mood if the place is
beautiful
it seduces you the ambiance is set not
just with comfortable furniture every
detail from the press tablecloth and
napkin the candelabra the flowers on the
table and of course the silverware where
everything seems natural like it belongs
but crucial is the lighting lighting is
probably the most imperceptible detail
that if the lighting is great you don't
know it if the lighting is awful you
sure know it to me flowers represent
life quite something and they also make
you aware even in the city that it's
possible to cultivate a garden even the
most urban of settings
great service for me is discretion great
service you don't even know you're being
served it's more about really listening
and being attentive to every single need
that the guests may have and to
anticipate a very good bartender for
instance will immediately see a guest
coming in and know exactly what that
guest will order consistency is key
you really have to attend to all the
details as if it was the first time with
the same freshness you have to approach
the table approach how you clean the
room how everything is cooked as if you
were doing it well you're recreating the
restaurant each day that that I think is
a basic consistency a typical mistake in
many restaurants that don't last a long
time to forget that the guests is really
the most important ingredient and a
successful restaurant that guests walked
in may have had the most horrific day at
the office comes in and you are actually
able to make them forget what a horrible
day was and all's well that ends well
with a great meal